ce qu'on sait pour le moment c'est que
ce variant il est plus contagieux on
sait pas si les plus graves ou moins
graves ou juste neutre sur le moment il
n'y a pas beaucoup de formes graves en
afrique du sud qui ont été décrits avec
cette forme là donc c'est plutôt
rassurant donc après et on a juste des
données on doit récupérer des données on
peut pas donner des rv toutes les
réponses d'un coup quand un rayon vient
de sortir il faut il faut un temps de
recherche nécessaires pour pouvoir en
tirer des coups il est arrivé en france
1 c'est ce qu'a dire que vous me dire
olivier ferrand il a des couilles après
bab le mans que du moment qu'on détecte
un nouveau variant le temps qu'on a des
textes il a déjà voyagé dans le monde
entier donc c'est pour ça que parfois
les mesures qui sont mises en place sont
pas forcément nécessaire alors est-ce
que si je fais ma troisième dose là je
suis protégé contre le vario au micro
encore une fois il faut voir à quel
point les mutations qui l' aquila qui
l'a les nouvelles mutations qui la lui
donne une capacité d'échappement au
système immunitaire il est certain que
la gravité du coc vie depuis le début on
l'a vu quand on n'a rien fait qd et même
si on peut être infecté par des nouveaux
par des nouvelles formes puisqu'il va
toujours échappé une fois qu'on est prêt
et immunisés c'est surtout la première
réflexion qui donne des formes mortelles
et des formes graves une fois qu'on est
prémuni zay soit par le vaccination
peuvent par le fait de l'avoir eue on en
fait moins d'accord alors aujourd'hui on
voit tous les pays d'europe et du monde
panique on va tout est en train de
fermer est-ce que ça va continuer parce
qu'on
ça c'est des décisions qui sont
politiques moi je pense que le var et
enfin on sent on va s'enfermer avec
notre propre variant au micro mikron
puisqu'il a probablement déjà diffusé en
europe donc il est probable qu'il existe
déjà en france donc après on veut fermer
les frontières parce que la seule arme
politique d peu des hommes politiques
c'est les frontières donc du coup il
utilise ça mais c'est pas forcément le
meilleur moyen pour stopper un nouveau
variant s'il a un avantage trajet
stratégique pour le virus c'est à dire
que s'ils donnent une meilleure capacité
d'infection et donc de reproduction il
va être sélectionné il va devenir
dominant le seul intérêt de fermer les
frontières actuellement c'est de se dire
on attend d'avoir un peu plus de données
on essaie d'éviter qui flambent trop
rapidement pour voir s'il faut réadapter
le vaccin la 3e 2 c'est rapide à faire
c'est rapide bas avec les vaccins arn on
peut faire c'est assez rapidement mais
après il faut lancer quand même tout
prêt sert production industrielle la
vente etc ne fait pas c'est rapide à
faire mais il a senti simple après
distribués oui mais quand même on voit
des grands pays qui ferment quand alan
l'australie il que l'on réfléchisse
l on n'est pas plus intelligent que les
autres pourquoi on ferme panneaux alors
le stralis depuis le début de cette
crise toujours utiliser la stratégie de
0 coville donc de fermer ses frontières
des caméras car c'est une il a donc est
allé percuter une particularité
d'adaptation israël ils ont ils ont dit
qu'il fermait les frontières pour
pouvoir permettre de circuler en ville a
précédé cdc la gestion politique mais là
c'est la politique par rapport à sa
population c'est ça c'est de la
politique
on dit que sa verrière qui vient
d'afrique du sud est-ce que forcément
les variants viennent des pays où on a
peut vacciner ou pas alors le fait
d'avoir peu vaccinés ça augmente notre
ca augmente le ca augmente la
circulation virale du moment qu'un virus
ce groupe produit puis se reproduit plus
circulent plus la défense de celui de
muter puisque à chaque fois qu'il va se
reproduire il a une chance de muter et
donc de de créer un nouveau variant donc
c'est forcément ça facilite ça favorise
le faire donc c'est pour ça que web
alors vacciner a chuté de question on a
vu que les pays avec israël ne fait
jamais vacciné voilà c'était les pays
numéro roy ont vacciné pourquoi
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la situation là
bas est ce que la sorte évidemment n'est
pas le moins y'a pas de y'a pas c'est
pas dramatique la situation en israël
met d'ailleurs la situation enfin dans
les pays qui sont là actuellement on
voit qu'il ya une augmentation du nombre
de contaminations en france par exemple
ou même dans certains pays où est-ce
qu'on a l'impression que quand il fait
chaud partout ça se calme quand il
commence à faire froid ça commence à
revenir c'est ça une incidence ou pas du
tout ouais les gens se regroupent plus à
l'impasse à ferrara là mais on peut pas
être serré apple a fait la preuve la
corrélation entre la température et la
circuler la parole pendant ce temps mais
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a un
taux de on a un taux de cas de 30000 et
35000 quand on avait autant de cas il ya
six mois un an quand il avait on avait
les réacs était plein et c'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui donc c'est grâce au
vaccin ça ça veut dire que la
vaccination est efficace oui oui valérie
bénard où j'ai une question est ce que
vous pensez pas qu'on va être dans un
sorte de cirque infernal assesseurs
pernal comme ça parce que il ya
évidemment les pays émergents dont
parlait notamment géraldine parce que
c'est ces pays émergents eux ils sont
pas vaccinés ou très peu et que donc
tout les variants vous venir de ces pays
émergents mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut
il faut faire marcher la solidarité
aujourd'hui tout le monde essaie de
faire marcher un instant est déjà trop
tard parce que déjà ils vont en avoir
pas mal
à lui envoyer novak à la danse et place
alors est ce qu'il faut faire une
troisième deux ici probablement que ça
peut être utile pour notre population
est ce qu'il faut aussi vacciner le
réseau population également donc en fait
il faut il faut réussir à tout faire la
solidarité je crois que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il faut activer
actuellement que ça manque dans le monde
karim non moi mais jamais j'ai
l'impression à écouter les discours
politiques les mesures que nous prenons
qu'on revient un peu à la case départ
c'est ça sexy toujours ce même sentiment
c'est que si le virus de l'inconnu quoi
il nous surprend toujours il a toujours
un temps d'avancé sur nous car est
pourquoi là vous nous dites fermer les
frontières c'est ce qu'on avait déjà dit
qu'il y avait des écarts de quai et on
boit bien effectivement la limite parce
que le virus lui et n'a pas de
frontières après derrière on dit
attention romelo masse que dans
certaines circonstances le masque il
fallait pas l'enlever d'un que pourquoi
on a on a on n'a pas accéléré sur les
variables et troisièmement et discours
qui sont très contradictoires le pdg de
pfizer je lisais avant de venir dit il
va falloir peut-être se vacciner avec
une dose de rappel tous les trois ou
quatre mois oui j'écoute est intéressé
infectiologues et chercheurs de
l'institut pasteur c'est à n'importe qui
et par ceux qui lui disaient tout le
contraire ils disaient mais peut-être
qu'il faut le faire circuler ce virus de
que notamment sur les populations n'est
qu'ils ne sont pas les plus vulnérables
maxime est plus grave mais le laisser
circuler parce que l'immunité collective
on l'aura plus facilement sur le fait
circuler sur les gens pour lesquels il
aura moins d'impact que que si on va t
on alors c'est toujours pareil on
revient à l'inconnu au sony mais on
alors que chaque hiver tu déjà converse
on verra à la case départ là tout le
monde a peur d'être confiné alors
toujours il ya toujours quand même dans
toute problématique des gens qui ont
désigné des avis différents donc le fait
qu'ils aient des discours
contradictoires sur un problème c'est
normal après le fait que le pdg de
pfizer disent qu'il fallait que chaque
vacciner tous les trois quatre mois
c'est quand même pas étonnant puisque
lui il a un rapport financier à ça la
question à ces prix là c'est bon mais je
pense que la question qui peut qui se
pose depuis le début cette crue et que
personne ce poste c'est pourquoi on a
pas ni l'europe à recevoir des loups
garous pourquoi on n'a quand même
pas pj
mais pourquoi je sais pas de faire de
pourquoi n'essaie pas de faire sauter
les brevets parce que c'est vrai que par
exemple un certain john hassall café le
café café le vaccin la poliomyélite il
n'a pas pris de brevets parce qu'il a
dit ce serait comme mettre un un brevet
sur le soleil donc tout le monde ne
cherche pas forcément à s'enrichir dans
la vaccination ou dans les médicaments
et c'est vrai que plus que la question
de savoir est ce qu'il faut des vaccins
troisième je pense qu'il faut des
vaccins mais par contre on peut se poser
la question de savoir pourquoi on fait
pas ce que dit les styles youtube
pasteur c'est quoi ça tient la route ou
pas alors aux actionnaires a blessé les
autres ap alors que je sais pas qui est
qui a parlé je pense qu'il faut vacciner
les plus vulnérables effectivement je
pense que pour pour une dose de rappel
pour garder une immunité peut-être plus
prolongée ça peut avoir un sens de faire
une troisième dose en tout cas pour les
+ 40 ans ça semble prouver pour les
hospitalisations et des formes graves on
a quand même des formes alors chez dws
sinon je n'ai pas vu sur mon hôpital
mais j'ai vu beaucoup de vent de 30 ans
j'ai eu des patients de 30 ans non
vaccinés qui sont venus là en
réanimation en fait dans cette crise là
dans la cinquième vague mais jamais je
n'ai pas une passion vaccinons pas de
patients vaccinés donc voilà je peux pas
dire sur cette population là mais les
études semblent quand même démontré qu'à
une efficacité donc à voir
[Rires]
ce que je voulais dire simplement dans
ces camps bay toujours en exemple israël
je me rappelle qu en israël ils sont que
68 % de la population vaccinée et nous
enfoncer année à 76 et quelques bons
déjà donc c'est petit à 110 au début
nanard jeudi à fernand léger ont regardé
derrière moi et c'était évident mais ça
a pris beaucoup d'avancé donc les
esprits la vente mais ils ont pris du
retard maintenant par rapport à
notamment messieurs je voulais dire
c'est que les maires ruraux du retard je
veux dire que les virus c'est normal
qu'ils en aient les que les variants
c'est normal avec un virus qu'il y en
ait d'autres mais attendez vous
m'écoutez ou pas et je vous dis au
modern art ils sont en train de
séquencer ce virus du sida avec la rn
pour essayer de trouver un bal yéti face
à mes 50 ans quand en train de sucer
tout le monde la menace
les labos arrêtent ils s'en foutent
plein les poches a fait ils veulent
qu'on se fatigue tous les 4 mois raideur
des conneries je termine en disant cadre
boisé temps quand tu la quittes offert
des bacs son
voyage le patron le fais taster ça sur
rfm
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aurait volé
bernard j't'adore non mais c'est surtout
parce que je dis
g
innocent sur un sérum donc j'ai cité les
trois mois mais préfère t'assure
solution si j'ai raison ou pas oui
me sentais je t'en supplie par un
soutien moi non mais je veux faire à la
ferme
aux animaux tv peut-être alors jamalski
répondait non mais juste nommé juste
qu'ils sont en train de réadapter les
vaccins dont pour pour fonctionner sur
les différents types de variantes voilà
presque il se peut que variante d'el
tarf le delta qu'on a voilà supplante
que nouveau parce que voilà c'est passé
avec les anciennes nos jours le bon jour
il au micro libre c'est toujours comme
ça on nous a dit on voit la gare
nouveaux
avantages et celui qui est un avantage
sélectif celui qui se reproduit plus
loin il va prendre l'aventage face et sa
wii comme moi au paddle oui ce cap un
phénomène inquiétant là c'est la flambée
dans les établissements scolaires c'est
vrai qu'il ya plus en plus le cloud
permet dans les collèges des profs
absents des élèves qui sont positifs ou
qu'à contacter ma maman ça non mais en
ce moment c'est vrai mais il a raison la
collection déco j'ai des copains fille
la semaine dernière elle a dû rester à
la maison parce que j'avais 1,4 kobe
dans sa classe la mienne elle était qu'à
contacter à la déchirer votre maison et
votre
au salon d'esthétique y sont en
péril non mais c'est bon
il ya beaucoup ce circuit des champions
russes sur dans les écoles donc c'est
vrai que c'est un foyer de contamination
important pour les pour les parents
alors après le problème c'est que les
enfants vont quand même pas beaucoup à
l'hôpital c'est pas eux qu'on voit en
priorité on les a beaucoup vu pour les
groupes l'épidémie dont que l'internet
est quand même beaucoup de spitz
alisation d'enfants est ce que je vous
dis tous les enfants moi mes enfants
chaque week-end ils attendent le
lendemain ils sont j'espère qu'il va y
avoir un cadre cosy demain je vous jure
que c'est vrai c'est un truc de ouf fois
et c'est vrai que là c'est de plus en
plus présent bon voilà que voici n'est
pas plus de faire le maillot de madame
touche a
contraint de reconnaître les erreurs qui
a deux ans avant le premier confinement
on avait un virus très présent à
l'étranger et non 0 c'est pas grave ça
la chinoise c'est un virus italien est
alors ou à l'étranger ça ferme sa re
confie nous on dit il n'y aura pas de
confinement n'y aura pas de couvre-feu
est ce qu'au gouvernement il pas
optimiste moi j'y crois pas quand ils
disent qu'il ya pas de couvre-feu qui
aura plus de confinement je pense que si
le variant qui traite qui est plus
contagieux circulent et qui donne des
problématiques hospitalière donc
puisqu'il ya le nombre de cas est
l'incidence sur l'hôpital en fait on
confine pour protéger les malades de
pauvres pour qu'ils puissent être
soignés mais déjà effectivement la non
là on a un problème c'est que l'hôpital
n'était en pleine crise moi je veux plus
chercher à l'hôpital tout à l'heure donc
je suis parti de l'hôpital il y avait 26
passion d'urgence qui ne savait pas
qu'il s'agisse de dormir dans les
couloirs et c'était pas de casque avec
ces packs avec le la sépaq avec le
comique parce qu'on manque de place à
l'hôpital cause du départ des soignants
puisque tout le monde quitte l'hôpital
donc on a des lits fermés parce qu'à
plus d'infirmières d'aides-soignantes il
ya plus de personnel etc cette
problématique là qu'il va justement
peut-être l'idée des restrictions des
prochaines restrictions plus que et bien
sûr que le coc vite va avoir un impact
mais le nombre de places à l'hôpital
savez ça va être un an je vous en ai
tous vus alors rapport à mario niveau du
vaccin dubai joker
faites ce que vous posez on n'est pas
obligé de me répond non c'est vrai que
j'ai pas trop envie de m'exprimer là
dessus très doux battront en vue
d'influencer aussi des jaloux
la même erreur que je peux vous dire
c'est que moi j'ai peur du coup au vide
voilà accord franchement d'accord on
peut vous le bon choix c'est déjà une
handicapée j'ai peur pour mon mari voilà
moi jusqu'à jus plus jeunes et tour mais
vraiment ça me fait flipper ouais ça je
vous le dis vraiment il est diabétique
enfin c'est très peur du coup vite
jetterait j'ai vraiment voudrais pas
qu'il l'ait quoi j'ai peur pour mes
proches et tout ça fait flipper quand
même là on entend ça c'est benjamin roy
il ya des gens qui savent pas s'il sait
boire dormir en réanimation et tous et
c'est vraiment terrible en fait c'est un
jour sans fin quoi on entend des choses
qu'on pensait plus haut mais c'est ça la
raison si on a un prénom que ça